Hi, I'm Christopher Hine. Today I'm
going to talk about how to make your
good. So, real simple. Um, I think idiag
is super tricky. I've talked about edit
in the past, but I want to talk about
the classic idi that you see, the really
big pretty one where there's a bunch of
movement and everything happens. That
mag is is really deceptively simple. And
deceptively simple because I've seen all
kinds of horrible variations of that.
Took me years of working on it to really
figure out what it's doing. And it's
really simple. So I'm going to talk
about that to you guys with Josh today.
Josh.
All right. So let's talk about edit and
the uh shocking simplicity of it. So uh
I've talked about this a little bit
before, but let's really talk about
edimi and what's happening. So if I get
edimi, right, which is hard to get, but
if I get edi, I want to maximize my edi
time. Now, edimi nag is a way to deal
with someone who's trying to minimize
your edi time, but there's a real simple
way to to get it in the beginning. Okay?
So, look, if I'm going by Josh eating me
this way, and Josh wants to follow me,
he's going to follow me from the
direction I came from. So, if I go this
way, he's going to follow me like that
as as I escape, right? Okay. So, that
means if I shoot a straight line,
basically once I'm past Josh, if he's
turning, he's going to be right behind
me. So, what I want to do is I
constantly want to move at an angle
behind Josh. And this will make it
harder for him to pick me up, right? So,
if I'm moving, right, and we'll just go
step for step, right? So, I step and
Josh starts turning and I step and Josh
starts turning and I step and Josh
starts turning. You can see I stayed
either going fast, it's not going to be
that step for step for step, but that's
the basic idea. Now, if I'm quicker than
him, I will disappear like a ghost,
right? As far as he's concerned, I will
just disappear and he will go like this
and stop and go. And I've seen it happen
in Geioaza before where someone made
perfect edi and the other person just
went, "Wait, where are they?" Because
it's really disorienting. So, I'm always
moving at an angle behind Josh and not
moving straight behind where I started
from Josh because behind Josh is always
changing. The edi point's always
changing, right? So, what I mean by that
is if we go step for step again and I go
this way, okay, and Josh's turn. Now
look, Josh's back is at an angle this
way. So this might still feel to me like
I continue on the path. I step, Josh
steps. Okay? Now I'm nowhere near Josh's
back, right? And if I step one more
time, Josh will actually have my back,
right? That's because I'm not changing
as he's changing. As Josh is changing, I
always need to change with him. Now the
essence that essence is what edidy meag
is, right? So the edi comes from that
happening. Now, another thing to import
important thing to understand is the
closer I stay to Josh during that exit
time, the more time I will buy myself
because it's further for him to turn.
And the further I get from him, the
easier it'll be for him to turn. Right?
So, what I mean by that is I'm going to
kind of shoot off at a little bit of an
angle. If I come behind Josh like this
and he takes a step, okay, and I take a
step and I'm going this way, he's going
to get behind me faster because I'm
giving him more room to work. Okay?
Instead though, if I go this way and I'm
getting closer to him, right? And see,
he steps and I step, I'm getting closer
to him. He steps and I step, I'm getting
closer to him. Right? Now, I'm not
saying that you want to stay close. But
in that brief moment that you're coming
behind him, that's what you're doing,
right? So, so we'll we'll go real time
here, right? So, let's say I'm here and
I'm just going to move quickly behind
Josh and you're going to turn around to
catch me. Okay? That's what we're
looking for, right? Is I'm buying that
time out and I'm making him go on a
further loop to catch me. And then when
he does that, it's going to make us
further away when he finally does catch
me. Right? So by the time he caught me,
he was around there. We were already out
of my eye. Right? So you can see that
again like this. So we'll go and then
we'll we'll just stop. So stop when I
stop. So we go stop. Okay. We are
already now at MAI, right? So this
doesn't happen protracted. I showed it
that way just so you could see step for
step why it works that way. But within
one step, if I'm cutting tight behind
him, I will be at MAI or greater by the
time he gets around, which is all I
really want. on. I want to buy that ma
eye distance, right? So that's what I'm
always looking for. Okay. Now, the idimi
nag throw is when someone's turning
faster than you can get out of there,
right? So if he turns ultra ultra fast,
even with those tricks that I just
showed you, you can't get out of there.
So the edit nag helps us deal with that.
So as I'm passing this guy, let's go
like let's go like this. Okay. So as I'm
passing that guy, and I can tell he's
already turning. So I've taken like half
a step, and he's already here, right?
Okay. I know that this guy is going to
turn around faster than I can get out,
right? So, he's going to be around the
faster. So, all I do is step into him.
So, I step across him. Now, what this
will do when we're in time here, so uh
let's step step. Uh sorry, sorry. Yeah.
So, here we are. Okay. So, he's going to
go step and I step across him like this.
I'm hitting him at an angle where he's
not ready to brace yet. So, what's going
to happen is he gets twisted up. So, as
he comes in to get me on this, I am
walking more and more behind him and
twisting up more and more and more. Now,
the faster he tries to turn around to
get me, it will actually make the edim
nag worse on him because when that's
happening, he is uh twisting himself
more. It's like he will do less with his
feet than he does with his core. So, the
faster he tries to go, he's going to
turn his core more and more and more to
get me, and that's going to make him
more and more twisted up. So, the more I
step across him, then the the the harder
the throw is going to be for him, right?
Or the harder the just more complicated
it is for him to get me. Okay? Now, that
doesn't mean also that my ediaga is
always going to work because in order
for that to work, I need to keep him
tight up top here and I'm going to try
not to hit my microphone. But as he
starts to turn, I have to have this
happening right now. If he could just
pull his head out of there and turn,
that'll be no problem for him. Right?
So, so I will have backups. Triangle is
a backup for that. Right? So, let's say
he does come around, boom, I go triangle
and I can pop right out of there as
well. But, I need to keep this all
tight. And so, that's what you're seeing
in this pulling the collar in tight so
he can't get his head around. Now, if
we're here like this and I keep his chin
locked in place, turn to get me. See, if
his head can't turn, then he messes up
his body even more, right? So, he's more
and more and more out of balance. So,
that's the really simple idea of eating
meag is as I'm moving behind this guy,
and it is happening like a flash.
Although, you got to kind of break it
down like this to intellectually get it.
But as as you're going behind him,
you're always trying to keep your edi
position, which is across his back. Now,
if he is turning faster than you can
make your exit in that, all you do is
step across him while locking his head
in place. And if you do that, he will
throw himself. It's not a big close
line, right? So this classic really
pretty edit, it's not a clos line. It's
just keeping his head in place. So as he
turns, his head gets left behind and
that discombobulates his body and he
can't stay standing anymore and it will
take just about zero effort to step
through someone like that because their
feet are all twisted up at that point.
Right? So that's what Edy Minag is
genuinely doing. I believe um I've seen
it happen live. I've seen it happen in
crazy situations because you're just in
tight like that and it's too hard to
turn around. So that's what your edaga
should be in my opinion and it's not
some crazy clothesline or some magical
technique or something else. Really,
really simple. So I hope that helped.
I'm Christopher Hines Joshua Tehi my
salon McDaniel's behind that camera
right over there which we can't decide
if it's soft yet. We haven't figured it
maybe something wrong with that lens. We
don't know. Anyways, all right. We'll
see you in the near future.